donc pour l'élection présidentielle au
procès de patrick dils maintenant
l'heure est aux plaidoiries après un
réquisitoire du procureur général qui
l'a exprimé que des doutes sur la
culpabilité de l'accusé vallée des
ermites fellering la dernière ligne
droite celle où il faut tenter de
convaincre les indécis transformer le
doute en intime conviction celle de
l'innocence de patrick dils les avocats
de l'accusé le savent leur plaidoirie
est essentiel puisque la veille l'avocat
général n'a pas levé toutes les
ambiguïtés n'a pas clairement montré le
chemin de l'acquittement au delà des
doutes de l'avocat général la défense
elle a une certitude des naissances et
nous allons tenter de les montrer
l'avocat général est habité par le doute
tout est douteux dans ce dossier dit il
mais il est aussi habité par la colère
suscitée par les aveux effroyable de
patrick dils ils ont tout balayé comme
un torrent dévastateur dit il ils ont
envahi la raison et si vous bénéficiez
du doute monsieur dils ayez une nouvelle
pudeur vous avez pris la place du
meurtrier ne venait pas disputer celle
des victimes vous n'êtes victimes que de
vous même on dit comment les coptes ont
été tués avec quelle sauvagerie qu'ils
ont été tués tout ça puis qu'on vient
nous dire
très bien le doute de l'avocat général
et les certitudes diamétralement
opposées des avocats des parties civiles
et de la défense le verdict très attendu
tombera dans la journée